[Applause]
okay
for being here today at the first I
believe PI data Los Angeles so first
thing to notice that yeah I'm Brian van
de van I'm not luke Canavan who was
originally scheduled to give that talk
I'm gonna be giving a very similar talk
as it happens I'm also the project lead
for bouquet and so I'm really most good
at maybe doing status updates for
booking so I'm gonna put a little bit of
that in this talk as well because it's
very timely we're actually gonna be
releasing a 1.0 release a bouquet this
week so that's exciting so I will give a
little bit of a status update and then
also talk about bouquet and now it can
be used to build data applications and
dashboards and give some examples of
that as well so first off who's familiar
with okay so fans or who's not familiar
with okay okay a good number of people
so I'm gonna go ahead and just quickly
go through sort of what bouquets about I
like to give this for recorded videos
anyway so that way if there's viewers
later they can make sure to have the
full picture so just to quickly
introduce bouquet bouquet is the tool
for interactive visualizations it allows
you to add all kinds of interactive
controls widgets you know dynamic sort
of aspects on a on a web page to
interact with you know PI data tools for
visualization it supports all kinds of
versatile and high level graphics we
want to make it possible to create very
I don't novel graphics but certainly any
kind of graphic you need to be able to
create hopefully you can do with bouquet
we also want to build a handle streaming
data so of large data any kind of
dynamic updating data if you've got data
coming in over some you know Ajax REST
API or you've got data that you're
streaming in from some you know market
source or some sensor we won't be able
to handle cases like that as well so
bouquet has facilities for that all of
this is for the browser right so this
generates HTML pages that are reactive
that have you know these visualizations
in them and that's with or without the
bouquet server so there's an optional
book a server component that's part of
bouquet that we'll talk about in a bit
that really allows you to connect all of
the actual you know pi data tools OpenCV
pandas numpy all of these things to
these visualizations very easily and
we'll talk about that in a bit
and also of course it works in the
Jupiter notebook right so everyone I
imagine is using the Jupiter notebook
for all kinds of exploratory data
analysis and so bouquet works really
well inside Jupiter notebooks and the
last thing of course is that there's no
JavaScript that you have to
sort of muck with repeats that no
JavaScript and that's not my way of
trying to like language shame I'm just
trying to say that you know all of us
probably are productive in Python that's
why we're here at iData we're productive
in our and julia and so book is really
about creating simple you know to write
apps for data science so we've got all
kinds of different domains where you
might want to create things allow you to
slice and dice or look into data across
filter data we might want to create you
know report type things we have a live
streaming spectrogram example they were
running scikit-learn you know all of
these things you own okay it's simple to
write data apps and so that's just you
know when I say no JavaScript it's more
about making it so you can concentrate
on your work you're already productive
you know in Python in our and you know
productive with all these Python tools
so let's let you stay in that productive
area and and still make these powerful
visualizations so there's mostly you
know written in Python if you want to do
some customizations you can do
customizations but to get a simple book
a page or book a application running
there's little or no HTML or CSS coding
required to do that and also the scripts
that you write themselves are very
simple and we'll see some examples in a
bit they look just like regular Python
scripts there's not some big framework
that you have to plug in or classes that
you have to subclass or you know you can
use all the organizational tools in
Python to organize your your bouquet
application if you want to but you can
also just write simple scripts and we'll
see some examples of that bouquet is
useful for a wide variety of use cases
people use it in the notebook for
exploratory data analysis and especially
in conjunction with pandas there are
folks that are starting to build
higher-level tools on top of bouquet
things called how the views how the
views is one example together with data
shader these are even higher level api's
that are really great for exploratory
data analysis and maybe i can link to
some of those in a bit the bouquet
server as i mentioned its main use case
is to automatically mirror state from
python to javascript we'll talk about
how bouquets actually put together some
concepts in a second but the bouquet
server lets you synchronize things
between Python and JavaScript very
easily so if I make a change in Python
if I update some data my my plot or my
graph can update if they user make a
selection on the plot I can transmit
that information back to Python and
react to it do other kinds of
computations or other kinds of analysis
on that than information and in general
we're trying to let people connect to
the full
I did a stack right these interactive
web apps as easily as possible as
frictionless as possible so we've got
numpy we've got type i i've got pandas
we've got scikit-learn and sk image all
these tools that are really fantastic
how do we sort of plug those into
interactive visualizations without
having to write a huge web app ourselves
so people have done a lot of interesting
things with bouquet as I mentioned we're
having a release here pretty soon this
has put me a little bit of a reflective
mood so I sort of went through Twitter
and found some examples that people have
done cool things with bouquet we can see
the dashboard we'll see that in a bit
more detail people are doing sort of
geographic and map type explorations or
some folks doing sports analyses there's
some astronomers who've been using
bouquet a lot to do some really cool
analyses on astronomical data and other
hard sciences folks and you know those
people who have used bokeh in a wide
variety of venues is obviously finance
folks they're using bouquet I know some
people in the pharmaceutical industry or
using bouquet so a lot of different
applications and use cases for bouquet
if I can pick on one this one just is
the most recent one I've I've seen this
is a couple of ghost lights light curve
and this is an example that was created
again by one of those astronomers so
they've got astronomical data coming in
and typically a lot of data so they want
able to drill down and sort of see all
kinds of different aspects of data and
so a bouquet allows them the tools to be
able to do that right we can have all
kinds of interactions panning and
zooming selections and then we can link
that to other plots and whatever these
kind of events happen you know we can
use the book a server to respond to
those events an update accordingly and
so that's been a very useful thing for
them to create ok so with that brief
introduction I want to talk a little bit
about bouquet today this is the status
update portion where bouquets today
we're attended a few words about that
and then we'll get into sort of the the
meat of the presentation in a bit ok so
just as a quick reflection again I'm in
a very nostalgic mood just to set the
stage this is circa June 2014 probably
the first sort of real release of
bouquet maybe 0.5 you can see we had
about you know 5,000 downloads a month
and it's pretty astounding to me and
humbling actually to see sort of where
we've come in those intervening years
right so now if you combine content pie
pie downloads it's well over half a
million installs per month and it's that
still blows me away
so there's a lot of people using bouquet
for a lot of interesting cases and I'm
really great
the opportunity to build this but all of
that's possible not because of my work
but because of an entire team of people
who have contributed to bouquet over the
years and has been just really fantastic
people who've worked on bouquet have it
Pennington one of the original gnome gtk
developers wrote the second-generation
bouquet server the reason it's so
fantastic is because he's fantastic
you know julia signal just added a long
time issue patches with holes which is
gonna help support contour plots and
some GIS use cases just added that in
41.0 philip and john luke or the howl of
use devs they've done some great work to
add new features that support howl of
use Mateus is you know one of our
stalwart sort of front-end JavaScript
developers of course the inimitable
Sarah bird has done a huge amount of
work to my bouquet look really good
better than sort of designed by
engineers look and so a lot of that's as
a result of her fantastic work so a lot
of people have worked but also a lot of
other people we just hit 322
contributors on github I think this
would be the final number before 1.0
release and that's again very humbling
and very amazing really grateful for all
those people I'd like to call it a few
special thanks to Carl Vander Plaats
Eugene Packham olive and Anthony dokely
augo's who we just recently recognized
at the gnome focus summit as sort of new
contributors and so they've done a lot
of really great work we're starting to
get the point where we get new
contributors to bouquet who are doing
more than just sort of a drive-by PR
they you know they submit five or six
PRS and they're a lot more in-depth and
so I really encourage anyone who's
interested in getting involved in
bouquet to you know come talk to us we'd
love to have new contributors great
places to talk to us are places like the
mailing list stack overflow
good for questions or there's a get our
dev channel which is a really good place
to come and talk to us as well okay so I
mentioned we're brown I have a 1.0
release this week it might be tomorrow
this travel has put a little bit of a
kink in my schedule so it might be
Wednesday I'll see what we do but some
of the new things that are coming in 1.0
as I mentioned julia added support for
multi polygons with holes this is sort
of a long time issue it just took a
while to get it done but that's actually
useful for things again like filled
contour plots or some different GIS type
plots so that's actually exciting to get
that in several fixes the data table you
know that's one of the more complicated
widgets we have to deal with and set
various issues I will say one of the
nice things as we've just put in
new infrastructure for integration and
selenium testing and so we're actually
able to maintain these I think a lot
better going forward and prevent some of
the kinds of regressions we've had in
the last year or so but anyway there's a
lot of fixes that are coming for data
table which is good we also added a
custom action so if you want to add your
own toolbar button that invokes a little
custom ji snippet and to do whatever you
want it's very easy to do that now to
have your own toolbar button we also
added a new way to export and embed okay
so you know part of the motivation in
making bouquet easy to use without
JavaScript was we we made some functions
that just returned like a script tag
that you can embed in a template but as
it turns out some folks actually want a
little bit more work to do on the ji
side and they would like just a pile of
JSON just the raw JSON that represents a
bouquet document and so we now have a
very simple JSON export that you can
pass to one function on the JavaScript
side to embed it in any Dib that you
want and so that's actually a very nice
thing so we actually this was inspired
by another talk we saw someone it shows
another tool besides bouquet and they
sort of explained what their rationale
was and they actually had front-end
developers who wanted a simple function
to embed this kind of JSON that they
pulled off a REST API and so now we can
do that as well at bouquet and I think
that's actually a very useful feature
similar lines we added a callback to the
Ajax data source so Ajax datasource is a
source that you can configure to look at
some REST API to pull in data
periodically it's a pretty useful tool
if you want to have a standalone page
that doesn't rely on the bouquet server
but that conceals for update dynamically
but until now it's needed to have the
REST API supplied data in a very
specific format but now there's a
callback that you can use to adapt any
kind of return that you get from that
REST API into the bouquet format and so
I think this makes the Ajax datasource
much much more generally useful we
should have done a long time ago
sometimes things just take a while but
I'm happy that that's going in now as
well another longtime feature that has
been asked for that we just now finally
got around to with a parameter izybelle
scatter type so right now if you're
applauding say the iris flowers data you
know you might have to plot circles for
the you know the one species and squares
and triangles for the two other species
and you have to make separate calls to
do that but now you can actually just
call scatter and you can use a marker
map to mark that categorical species
type to squares or circles and so I
think this opens up a different kind of
usage that I think will be really useful
now that we have these
notions of mappers and transforms in
boquete this is why this made more sense
to do now than it did earlier but we
finally got around to it and so I'm
happy that's gone as well we also
changed the way that the web drivers are
allocated for PNG and SVG static exports
previously we always spun up a new web
driver for a BX board it was kind of
slow you could create your own web
driver to make that faster and to pass
it in by hand but now it just does that
by default so Keynes yet SVG exports
should be quite a bit faster by default
and also import times we spend a little
bit of time optimizing for import time
so bouquet is a pretty big sophisticated
library right we're getting down to
about as low and import time as we can a
lot of its taken up by numpy or pandas
if you're using it but there might be a
little bit more time but certainly it's
able to make some strides for this
latest release and so I'm happy for that
as well
so that's a lot that's going to 1.0
obviously leading up to that there's a
lot of other features that are already
in boquete of course you can see the you
know the docs and the user guide and
examples sort of get a feel for those
things okay so what about some basic
principles of bouquet that we can use to
build sort of applicated aid
applications or dashboards as the talk
was was titled so first off just to
mention how bouquet works sort of at a
very high you know bird's-eye view you
know bouquet has a Python objects as an
API in Python lets you create you know
pile of objects things like plots and
data sources AXYZ tools ranges all kinds
of objects you know custom J's callbacks
all of those exist in this you know
these Python objects and those can get
turned into a JSON format and then that
JSON that pile of JSON is consumed by a
JavaScript library called bouquet Jas
and that JavaScript library Boca Jes
reconstitutes that JSON into it an
identical set of objects on the
JavaScript side and then it uses those
objects to actually render canvas SVG
output WebGL output in some cases and so
that's a really flexible architecture
you can sort of see this in action if
you use the low-level bouquet top models
API you can create these kind of objects
like a circle glyph and then you can
sort of call to JSON you can see yeah
it's got just all the stuff that you
would expect or the attributes the
properties of this circle clip and so
the bookid out models api is this this
api this mirror on both the javascript
and the the python side they're sort of
object in Python matching an object in
JavaScript and JSON that goes between
them so if this was if I was Luke and
Luke was giving the saw he'd go on and
talk more about mochi models he really
likes the bouquet model sort of the
low-level building blocks API cuz he
wants to build things up from scratch I
like to work for sort of the
higher-level bookid uh plotting api so
i'm not gonna talk too much more about
polka dot models just to mention that
it's there and that's what the other
api's are built on top of well one
consequence of having this architecture
is that it's nice and fairly
straightforward to make bouquet bindings
for other languages so someone has
actually done that for instance for our
Ryan - who's on the none focused
steering committee for bouquet is
created our bouquet right and so it's
just our code and our API that can
generate that same pile of JSON and as a
result it can generate bouquet plots
from our code right so if you want to
use bouquet from our you can there's
also a bouquet scholar project it hasn't
gotten a lot of attention lately
the mateus maintains but I'd love to
create as many language bindings for
bouquet as we can I think Julia and
bouquet would be a great combination
there actually was a Julia binding for
bouquet several years ago very long time
ago and the person maintaining it just
had to move on to other things but I
would love to get someone from the
Dooley community to help make you know
bouquet Jael so you could use bouquet
with Julia but any language you know we
could make MATLAB I'll threaten to do
MATLAB bindings for a bouquet I won't do
that
someone else could do that if they want
to but if you want to check out our
bouquet you can go to github it's under
Ryan - skit hub under the our bouquet
project okay so another general idea for
bouquet is that we want to be able to
map attributes sort of visual properties
to data columns so what do I mean by
that so one of the fundamental objects
or models in bouquet is this thing
called the column data source and the
best way to think about it is just sort
of as a cheap pandas dataframe right
it's a mapping of names to sequences of
data this could be a raised that could
be Python lists it could be pandas
series doesn't really matter they all
need to be the same length just like in
a data column or a data frame but it's
the same idea right so I create a column
data source here from a plain dictionary
I've got a time value in color columns
in my column data source that mapped to
sequences I can create a figure and then
when I call this glyph method circle I
can say that hey I want to
the x-coordinates to the time and I want
to map the y-coordinates to the value
column and I want to map the fill color
to the color column there's a lot of
different attributes that you can map to
data in this way and then you can update
the column data source in JavaScript
callbacks in Python callbacks and okay
server applications and that will cause
the visualization to update accordingly
so these column data sources have a
couple of other methods in a one way we
can update the data is just to set it
data attribute so if I call source data
equals some new dictionary that will
update all the data for this plot and
all the glyphs will update but there's
also some other particular cases that
are useful in bocas server applications
there's a streaming API so if you have
data coming in you know new data
continuously it's inefficient to sort of
update all the data every time so you
can sort of just send them marginal
increments to your data using that
stream or if you need to like update in
the middle of your data store read-only
access in the middle of a large data set
there's a dot patch maybe a quick quick
demonstration actually so I'll just show
the here's the OHC ohlc demo so this
stands for open high low close so this
is kind of like financial data so you
imagine sort of data coming in you're
showing these candlesticks for the data
it's computing a moving average of some
sorts also committing these MACD
indicators this script actually
generating synthetic data for the
visualize visualizer to use but that's
all under 100 lines of Python including
the simulation a lot of the code is
actually for the simulation but you can
see it's just you know reactive to these
widgets if I want to change the mean and
now we make a lot of money and we can
start seeing that you know our profits
go way up and I can make things a lot
more volatile by increasing the standard
deviation if I want a different you know
exponential average I can do that you
can see where it changed there in the
middle so that's you know that's I guess
an example of this streaming API and we
could actually take a look at bouquet
example so in the github repo the
examples directory is a great place to
go look for example code so if we look
at examples app ohlc
if we go to main top I this is the
entire scripts right so that's the
entire script to get that an interactive
streaming web app is all of this code
and a good chunk of this code again is
the actual simulation code there in the
update step so anyway that was a quick
example of this streaming API so that is
useful thing and the patch is similar
again patches if you don't want to if
you want to update just one or two items
in the middle of a big array it's
inefficient to send the whole array so
patch lets you send just just the new
items very efficiently okay
another feature that's nice for bouquet
is styling as we've seen there's Python
api's for controlling things like visual
appearance of all of the you know the
axes or the titles or you know fonts and
line widths for grids and things like
that but you can also put this
information in sort of a declarative
gambol or JSON format and then load this
is a theme and that's actually really
useful if you want to have a consistent
look across several pots and a dashboard
for instance you can just dump all of
that inside this sort of bouquet style
sheet if you will and you can pretty
much target any any property on any
bouquet object right so here we've got
you know attributes for axes I want to
set all the you know the line colors for
the the major and minor ticks I want to
you know set the font size for the
labels I want to you know set the grid
line color to Knohl or whatever so we
can make our plots consistent very
easily without having to write a little
code by using these style sheets
recently we've had some user contributed
Styles and this is actually a great
place for anyone who's interested in
getting involved to plug in you could
create new styles and we could talk
about getting those added to bouquet but
there's the caliber Monica dark and
minimal dark styles or some things that
have gone in recently definitely you
know there's some improvement we'd like
to make to the styling mechanism itself
another great place for new contributors
to get involved if you want to you know
look at a project to get involved with
okay sounds another thing bouquet can do
is let you layout different objects on
the screen right so bouquet has sort of
a built in layout capability that's
based basically on rows and columns
right so here I'm using the layout
function I can give it a list which
lists rows of things and each each
excuse me each each row lists several
objects several columns and so here you
can see sort of a dashboard type layout
I've got my Bollinger plot returned on
the top and then I've got the slider
which actually returns a row with a
bunch of widgets inside it and then a
plot and then I've got this linked
panning which returns a row with three
plots in it I can set my sizing mode to
stretch both so if I make my let you
know browser bigger or smaller than the
you know the plots get bigger or smaller
so this is sort of example of that I
will say you know it's it can't be
responsive I'll say that our current
layout system you know it has some
problems
issues I think it's fair to say that we
bit off a little bit more than we could
chew so there's actually some work
ongoing now a fairly large
work-in-progress PR that really
simplifies our layout system greatly and
tries to sort of make it one much faster
but a lot simpler we were relying on a
constraint for basically to do our you
know our layout and it turns out that's
kind of overkill and it's also hard to
manage and so we're we're making
something a little bit simpler a lot
faster for especially if you want to put
sixty or hundred plots on a page the new
layout system work better it's just kind
of a big PR and a big effort so we
didn't put in for 1.0 because it was
kind of a little too risky this late in
the game but we'll have a 1.0 release as
soon as we can that has that sort of
layout but regardless of whether sort of
bookcase built-in layouts work for your
case if you have something sophisticated
it doesn't we also support custom
templates and so this is sort of the
relief mechanism works you really want
to customize the look of something if
you want to use for instance some
bootstrap you know dashboard template
that you found
how can you embed boquete components in
this template and there's basically a
few different little bits and pieces and
I'm going to go over this quickly and
we'll see a concrete example here in a
few minutes but there's a embed from
macro too to sort of add this is a
ginger template bouquet provides us in
bed macro there's up in the the head of
the document there is a place where you
to supply the book ajs resources or
actually the bouquet will supply those
if you put those those template
parameters there and then you can embed
bouquet objects so if you're familiar
with okay there's this notion of a
document and you could add roots to a
document you might add a plot as a
document root or a layout as a document
root or you might have several different
document roots you can individually
embed all of these document root s--
wherever you want you've got some
reactive you know bootstrap layout here
inside this div you want to embed plot
one and inside some other div you want
to embed plot two this is the syntax you
do to do it each of those you know you
can give a name to each of these plots
and then you just refer them by name in
the template and it will put the right
thing there then there's some
boilerplate at the bottom so that's sort
of the roadmaps using that and what's
nice about that is again you can use for
a standard you know bootstrap template
or whatever you know whatever sort of
layout system you want and you can just
target divs to put in you know bouquet
plots and if you've set the bouquet
plots to have you know a sizing mode
that's scales or stretches
then as the
the enclosing gives gets larger smaller
book able to react to that specific
example of usage is the desk UI has a
diagnostic a diagnostic UI the desk has
and it uses boquete extensively and it
also uses this template in capabilities
familiar with tasks few folks like I
said task is a great library written by
Matt Rocklin or remotely I mean several
people work on it now but initially
created by Matt Rockland it's for
distributed to write computing it's
really fantastic let me actually see if
I can pull up an example here see
another quick live example so thank
actually there we go to ask examples so
all of these are available on my binders
let me actually load this and see how
long this takes I might come back to it
so desk is a panda slack API for
basically distributed computing and so
he has a lot of examples that are up
here that you can look at but if we take
a look I think at the future stripey Y&B
this is all running in a Jupiter lab on
my binder and so we can execute some of
these cells for desk and we should see
the actual task stream pop up here there
we go and so if we actually execute some
desk code to do a computation we'll
start to see it update we do more tasks
you know you can start to see the task
graph sort of fill up I'm gonna execute
a bunch of things yeah so this lets you
sort of see how the CPU utilization goes
across and what are all the actual tasks
that are running is so that mattre often
use this you know use bouquet to provide
this diagnostic UI because it makes
diagnosing any issues with you know
tasks you've seized much simpler because
you can really drill down into you know
what here was the increment tasks the
add tasks you can see exactly what's
going on and you didn't have to write a
web app to do this you could do this all
basically with okay and so actually this
is the point where if loop were here it
gives even more detail because it
actually wrote I think most of this
along with Matt Rockland but anyway
that's a nice example but of course the
main thing of want to mention with that
is you know you can read we can
rearrange these you know if we put this
over here that all this stuff you know
sort of reacts to that exactly as you'd
expect right so that's because if we're
using this custom template embed
capability okay
yeah okay so another thing that's worth
mentioning is custom extensions I'll
mention this very briefly just to say
that bouquet is extensible right so the
core team will never be able to do every
awesome idea that users have right there
a lot of great ideas that people have
that you know for whatever reason we
couldn't consider putting in the library
itself just because maybe we don't have
the resources to maintain it or maybe
it's very too specialized but now you
can actually go ahead and extend bouquet
you can create a JavaScript
implementation that maybe either
implement some cool widget or wraps some
existing widget and then you can use it
just like any other bouquet model right
so here we're creating you know this
custom widget it's an instance of a
slider with an extra custom text and
then I can use it kind of hard to tell
here the slides are online on slide deck
by the way but you can use this just
like any other bouquet widget right like
you would normally put a slider in a
layout or you know a drop-down and
layout you can use this custom widget
just like any other built in bouquet
widget and so there's a lot of
documentation for how to create those
extensions on the docs page but this is
useful for things like wrapping
different widgets so this is the ion
range slider I think not built into
bouquet but you can use it with bouquet
by writing an extension to do that you
know if you want to wrap some 3d library
there's no 3d capability built into
bouquet but you can wrap 3d j/s widgets
and connect them to PI data tools by
using bouquet adding latex labels one of
our longer-term goals is to make this
more built-in but right now if you want
to use latex labels you can use a custom
extension to do that and the main idea
is just that the committee doesn't have
to wait on us right there's a lot of
room here people to create a lot of
interesting extensions and I think if we
can get to a point where we can make the
extensions easily shareable between
people it'll really magnify their value
across the community okay
last little bit before some demos is
just talking about bouquets server
applications so I mentioned how bouquet
has a bunch of objects on the Python
side they're mirrored on the JavaScript
side mediated by this JSON
representation more or less the role of
the bouquet server is to not only just
take that Python representation and put
it into the browser and just say there
it is you know you're on your own but to
keep things and synchronized
automatically right so if I have an
object that I've taken Python it
automatically updates in the JavaScript
side and replot or
whatever and similarly if I slide a you
know a slider on a book a widget then
that information come back to the Python
code and run a regression you know or
update the data somehow so every time
you connect to a book a server page it
runs this application code creates this
set of Python objects in the document it
communicates to the page using
WebSockets and sends the JSON over or
for the case of numpy rays it can also
send the data over in a special binary
format that's much more efficient and
then we get this canvas HTML canvas
output and dom output as well and so
those are kept in sync so for every no
user that hits a bouquet server
application they get their own session
with their own document their own
objects it's not like a shared you know
Google Docs editing kind of situation
but that's automatically keeping these
things and think is sort of the purpose
of the bouquet server and we saw that
when I did the ohlc
demo and I you know I move the slider
and the simulation changed right that's
because I had a callback that responded
to that slider change and could do new
work and cause the outputs update and
that's what the bouquet server affords
just as a quick example we can define
functions like this update function we
can attach it to a select so if the
value of these select widget changes it
can call that update function and change
for instance the plot title you can
change the data source you could change
it pretty much any aspect of the plot
that you want to change you can change
it from one of these callbacks and you
can attach the callbacks to pretty much
any property there's also events that
you can attach callbacks to things like
mouse move events clicks you know all
kinds of different selection events
things like that so there's a pretty
rich system for attaching these kind of
callbacks to do work in response to any
kind of UI happening there's also some
document level callbacks as well if you
want to have a you know periodic sort of
push model where you update data you
know you can add a periodic callback
that runs every 100 milliseconds and
updates the data somehow and then beyond
that it's also possible that sort of
more pull like models the desk the the
desk UI uses that and you can sort of
look at the desk UI source code if
you're kind of curious it's kind of a
more advanced case but they actually add
their own asynchronous handlers to
tornado and so they can actually sort of
have a pull model for data ok
let's see so let's stop at an actual
concrete example sort of a full one
small amount of code but hopefully
illustrative of these these things I
want to build sort of a streaming or a
book application that can do sort of
face counting using open CV right so
this is a nice example I think because
it demonstrates that streaming API that
I mentioned it also shows connecting to
PI data tools right so we're creating
this bouquet application that uses open
CV to do this face detection and they
were also using a custom layout for the
nice look so briefly go over the code
what it looks like anyway
and then we'll check it out we'll run it
and we'll see how it works so here's the
entire Python bits and this is too small
on the screen I realized so I'm
definitely not gonna spend a lot of time
but just to briefly point out things
there's some open CV code right up here
some import some open CV code here's our
plots we create an image plot to
actually show the image we create a
rectangle glyph on that to highlight the
faces we've detected we create this time
series plot at the bottom actually shows
a count of the number of faces as a step
lot here's our update function so it
creates a grayscale to pass to the the
Cascade for detection it creates an RGB
eye image to pass through the bokeh
image cliff and then it simply sets
those data sources you can see the
rectangle source data equals this new
data the image source data we're
updating some values there and in
particular here at the bottom for the
time series we call dot stream and we
call just the new values and so that
very efficiently updates that time
search spot last thing is we add these
routes I mentioned document routes so I
say cur talk add route for the image
plot Karaka add route for the time
series plot which I've given some names
over there and then I can refer to those
in the template so this is the entire
template again hard to see on the screen
here's that part I mentioned where we
have the book IDs resources here is just
some content you'll see on the side just
lorem ipsum filler content here's that
part where I embed the root so I'm bed
routes dot image and routes TS right for
time series and those will show up and
so let's actually give this a go and see
how that goes
it's right here should have a nice
camera oh I actually hit enter wait for
that to start up there we go right so so
I've got my little camera here it's
doing a face detection brothel face
detection you can see that it's showing
you know 1 1 or 2 depending on what it
does the faces here I'm gonna just point
around I've never seen it work on a
crowd we'll see how well works ok so we
can see there's more faces there that's
pretty cool
Luke Luke warned me that that would work
pretty well but I hadn't actually ever
tested it on the crowd so thank you guys
for having obliging faces which actually
is a good point to consider I don't
usually you know lecture things but uh I
will say briefly you know I think this
you know this stuff is super cool right
I mean in terms of like technology but
uh I don't know at the risk of
belaboring a point I would say be
mindful of what you're putting all these
wonderful tools you know and what uses
you're putting them to for instance this
face detection I don't know much about
this har cascade at all are there faces
that recognizes other faces it's not
good at recognizing what implicit biases
are built into it so just you know these
are really powerful tools we've all been
you know I've been given by the open
source communities so let's try to put
them to good uses and do good things
with them and my only two cents there ok
let's see so that was the light demo we
already did that some final thoughts and
then we'll take some questions I think
we're actually pretty good on time first
off there's a list of resources here
obviously not so good on the screen here
but if you go to that speaker deck if
you go to my speaker deck Brian V this
presentation is available to actually
poke a and it has the links all of use
here there's things like github if you
want to make issues or you want to you
know get involved in developing the
documentation page bouquet I did org
actually and slash latest is all the
documentation there's a user's guide
there's a reference guide there's a
developer guide to get started you know
building bouquet and getting to work on
it
live tutorials if you just got a github
there's a link to this this we have all
of our tutorial notebooks on my binder
so you can go actually play around with
them you know live working notebooks and
experiment ok the mailing list we use is
pretty active Stack Overflow is a great
place to ask questions about bouquet to
for usage or other kinds of questions
and of course we have a git er chat
channel it's a great place to also
come and talk to you other users or some
of the core developers okay last call to
action you know it's stalled okay check
it out they're really licensed BSD
license including the server github com
okay so I spoke okay hopefully still
working seemed like github had some
issues this morning if anyone else
noticed fun fun night for everyone there
I'm sure also you know if you can if
you're able at you or your organization
organization could consider donating to
tube okay Bynum focus all right so last
year bouquet became an unfocused
fiscally sponsored project really very
happy about that that's always been the
long-term goal you know voce has been
force it to have a stream of sort of
institutional support both through the
original DARPA X data grant that we got
and then through anaconda but you know
as time goes on we're gonna need to sort
of find ways to push poke a bit more in
the community and this nun focus step
was a really great first step so
certainly if you have the ability to you
know help contribute to open source
software or your organization does you
know you can do that freedom focus and
then focus is a great organization
that's why we're all here today last
thing is to you know engage companies
for work so we're getting to the point
where people are starting to do work
around bouquet which is again amazing to
me people that want to do you know
integration work or build up more
sophisticated things and so I think
that's really cool really awesome I know
a few folks that are interested in doing
that sort of thing and companies that
are so if you interested in any kind of
commercial engagements feel free to
reach out to me or book a plot that
email comm and we can try to put you in
touch with the right folks because
that's always very good you know that
kind of feedback from actual real users
and use cases is probably the best the
best stone to sharpen the tool on right
sometimes I feel like I'm a I'm a
tinkerer and I develop this library but
I'm not actually a user and so maybe I
missed some important use cases and so
getting that feedback is a very valuable
loop for us to sort of close things okay
so that is pretty much all I have for
the presentation I think we have about
ten minutes now which actually worked
out pretty well
I shouldn't act surprised I guess and so
we can take some questions and and yeah
and we have a microphone so if you have
question just raise your hand and
thank you for this great presentation my
question is obviously we can see that
these dashboards would be very useful
internally in different companies but I
was wondering if you have any use cases
or companies have been using these
dashboards to external users and if you
can share with us these different use
cases that's a great question
the perennial or a perennial problem and
open source is that if things work
that's great people use them and they
don't necessarily call home and tell you
about them we were trying to start doing
a user survey every year where we could
try to solicit some of this information
back I don't have any specific examples
I can point you to I do know folks have
done some work too for instance I think
there was just a recent thing we tweeted
out about someone put together a nice
blog post about how different since host
a bouquet app on it's like digital ocean
or there's some other some other you
know system like that and sort of start
to finish instructions for doing that
and so I can't point anything specific
unfortunately you know the people their
problems we get all the issues github
and we get feature requests but when
things are working you know people just
use it and a lot of stuff is internal as
well
I'm definitely know folks who are using
it internally for you know dashboards
and things behind you know behind
corporate networks but I can't point
anything specifically public at the
moment I mean I see thing from time to
time like ok it's great but no one's
made it like a big announcement as in
terms of like a public facing one I know
it good question hi thank you for that
yeah the tool it's really awesome how do
you see yourself in relation to d3 do is
there any overlap or is there I get a
lot of corporate clients are like oh
they're variants in d3 I can point out
all the libraries like this yeah but
they're all focused on d3 yeah
absolutely yeah absolutely so what's the
relationship between bouquet and e3 and
the short answer is that there's not one
so book is not built on d3 for instance
that's a question that's come up so
bouquet draw is currently on HTML canvas
directly it's a raster you know canvas
for drawing we have some WebGL
capability and we're just expanding that
and the future that's one of our areas
of work tasks that we'd like to work on
the main thing I would say is that what
bouquet gives you that d3 doesn't is
that it lets you connect all of those PI
data tools that I talked about directly
to these visualizations without having
to write the d3 or the HTML code right
necessarily you know d3 is a fantastic
tool and it lets you make really
wonderful
visualisations it's kind of an artisanal
tool and there's like a you know failed
b3 experiments tumbler comm or something
because it requires a little bit of work
and don't get me wrong some things in
boquete require a little work too it's
just a matter where you know where have
the different tools optimized for and so
you know if you've got people up and
running a productive using panda since I
could learn and all of these tools
already and they want to get them up and
running as fast as possible I would say
bouquet is gonna be faster than saying
you know pointing with the d3 Docs and
say okay make a website and figure out
how to serve the data and figure out how
to get it into the page and then figure
out to use DFU to render it you know if
you've already got people working you
know in that sphere and in front-end
Devon d3 is a great tool but if you have
people that don't want to have to climb
another learning curve bouquet is a
fantastic way to get them up and running
as quick as possible
good question thank you yeah other
questions a couple over here similar to
the last question is there any known
ways or open-source examples of
integrating bouquet widgets or pages
into existing savory act apps or other
front-end frameworks so I mean the the
docs I think have some examples of that
kind of thing the you know I can't point
to any specific use cases we have a
variety of different ways to embed and
so you can embed things into tubes and
if you make the the bouquet content you
know reactive and the div responds the
bouquet bot will get bigger or smaller
you know if you look actually at the the
app here I didn't actually show off the
responsive part let me run this again so
this is a bootstrap one but I think it'd
be pretty similar for react if you run
this but you know if I make this smaller
then all the sudden you know this
updates right so I've got now that works
because this is embedded in the
bootstrap layout I think the story is
pretty much the same for react I'm not
actually I'm actually not a front-end
dev expert and I never really used react
myself but you know I think this it's
sort of the same story is that you can
embed you know these bouquet components
that have a sizing mode that allows them
to scale inside whatever content you
want and that's and this allows us to
not have to try to own the layout
problem is yeah you can use reactor you
can use bootstrap or whatever you want
but you know if you have specific
questions I would say the mailing list
is a great place or Stack Overflow and
we can try to hash out you know the
specifics but I don't I don't foresee
any problems with using okay with react
good other questions
hi I want to know more about how active
is currently in development right now
and how often do you plan to release
your minor version yeah good question so
about the activity development so right
now there's sort of one-and-a-half
people working I say I've okay pretty
regularly I think that the institutional
funding for okay it's gonna taper off
here so anacondas focusing on some
different priorities and so I think as I
mentioned it's a great time to get
involved trying to find other ways to
support people obviously you know I'm
personally attached to voce as a project
that I really believe in and want to
move forward so the question is you know
what will that be you know right now the
development is still very active we have
reached this sort of plateaus 41.0
plateau and that's not to get indicate
that we're done there's still plenty of
bugs and some features to implement but
it does indicate that we've reached you
know I think a plateau of stability for
like the API and so I think that gives
us some breathing room right and I'd
like to have much faster cadence on like
micro point releases and then have like
the one point one release maybe every
few months something like that I can't
commit to anything specific because the
thing that's contingent on sort of
funding avenues and things like that but
that's my suggestion would be you know
maybe a point release every and a couple
three or four times a year and then and
then a micro point release a little more
often which are much smaller targeted
type releases yeah other questions oh so
thank you for your talk a lot of these
questions have been technical mine is
gonna be more like squishy philosophical
but you know when you said I'm a teen
core yeah I'm just curious like what do
you mean by that in this context sort of
tell me about that identity and how its
kind of informing this work you know I
like taking things apart and putting
them together but I'm not like a data
scientist for instance and I would never
claim to be a data Sciences so people
who are using bouquet for data science
are doing work that I'm not especially
familiar with and so a lot of times
requirements for tools like these are
really I mean you know from a broad
stroke cuz like oh I worked on
visualization tools before and so I have
some idea and familiarity with that
space and what's useful but when you get
down to it there's always little things
that can make a big difference
and sometimes if you're not actually
familiar with the use cases knowing what
little things make the most difference
right is the thing that you missed
right and so on I'm not using bouquet
day-to-day to like do work I'm working
on bouquet day-to-day but that's
different than like using bouquet and
running into like hey here's a rough
edge that I didn't know about because
I'm not actually doing daily data
science work with it or daily science
work with it and so that's that's sort
of what I'm getting at is that you know
when you do work with something today
you get very familiar with like all the
little corners and little rough edges
and you know maybe I miss those because
I'm not doing that kind of work and so
that's where I say it's very valuable to
get this you know feedback loop from
users new user perspective is also very
incredibly valuable
you know if someone comes to bouquet for
the first time and can't figure anything
out that's important for us to know or
if they can't figure some specific thing
out maybe we can make it better right
but that's you know I'm so far in the
forest and in the trees right now that
you know I don't necessarily see those
things yeah good question thank you
other questions that come here all the
questions are on this side of the room
my question is about the bouquet and are
shiny yeah so is our bouquet the same or
in terms of efficiency and the ease of
use similar to bouquet and how would you
don't know if you have used our have
seen our show here before how you know
would you compare these two - yeah I've
I've definitely seen are shiny and I
would compare the Python bouquet server
fairly directly with miss shiny right
you know in terms of being able to
connect you know in that in the case of
shiny our tools directly to front end
visualizations very easily with the
minimum of sort of web tech coding and
the bouquet server lets you do that for
the Python side our bouquet currently
lets you create standalone type
documents from bouquet and by that I
mean you know you can have lots of
interactions you can have panning and
zooming linked panning linked selections
you can have custom jeaious tools you
can have just custom dance actions
reflections you can have a very
interactive page but it's not connected
to any server and so our bouquet can
generate those kind of plots today I
think Ryan's prepping another release
too soon it's been a little bit of while
he got kind of busy but I think he's
prepping a new release to update our
bouquet to a much more recent version
hopefully you're in the very near future
but he's got a really nice page put
together on if you go to his github you
can sort of see what it can already do
and you know depending on what you're
doing if you're already using bouquet
with Python I think it's a nice
mix and match right cuz you can embed
you know you could imagine embedding
things from our or from Python very
easily in the same page and I think
that's where the value lies and also how
they look and appear similar so okay
we're out of time okay
thank you again Brian
[Applause]